i think for a lot of people the most
jarring aspect of this columbus shooting
story where the girl tries to stab the
other girl and then the cop shoots the
girl with the knife
the most jarring aspect of it is how
this is in
any way controversial we are seeing this
with our own eyes
you see the girl with the knife inches
from the other girl
the cop waits until the very last minute
but then he blows away the
the threat rather how on earth could
anybody
deny this how could anybody not trust
what they're seeing with their own eyes
and the answer is very simple the
establishment media the left-wing media
the mainstream media
will not let you see that reality with
your own eyes
nbc news just got caught doing this
lester holt at nbc
introduced the story said here's what
happened you've got to check out this
footage
plays the footage and then nbc
edits the footage so you never see the
knife
just before yesterday's verdict a police
officer shot and killed a 16 year old
black girl in columbus ohio
saying she was threatening others with a
knife police body cam video was quickly
released
our kevin tibbles has that story and i
need to caution you the images are
difficult to watch
police body cam video shows micaiah
bryant's final moments
when a columbus ohio police officer
responding to a call
gets out of his car and seconds later
fatally shoots the 16 year old girl
authorities say bryant was threatening
two other girls with a knife
it's a tragedy
there's there's no other way to say it
it's a 16 year old girl
reardon fires his weapon four times
striking bryant
officers are seen and heard performing
cpr
body camera footage shows a knife on the
ground
no body camera footage shows the knife
in the girl's hand
inches away from the other girl's throat
and then you edited it out
you can see the way they they pause the
frame so that
you can the the knife is out of frame so
you can't see it but they kept the audio
going so you just hear the gun fire
officials say the girl was hold no not
officials say the video
shows that the girl had the knife at the
other girl's throat
but they edit it out because they won't
let you see it is it any wonder
there's controversy anyone who would see
the footage
anyone who would acknowledge the footage
would know the cop was completely
justified so what's the left guy to do
to push their narrative
they can't let you see that so the
footage shows the girl
with the knife inches away from the
other girl that she's about to stab
nbc news edits that out no that's that's
not part of it their excuse probably is
we didn't want to show
footage of the girl actually being shot
well then why did you edit it so
perfectly
where the knife is just out of frame
body cam footage is not the only footage
we have by the way
there is more footage from across the
street where someone was
not intervening not trying to help just
filming the thing but at least now we
have this footage
of the knife-wielding girl screaming
just before she is shot screaming i'm
gonna stab
the f out of you blank
and there it is it's a little bit hard
to hear obviously in the melee and the
audio's
further away but she does say i'm going
to stab the
f out of you blank it's you couldn't
you couldn't script it any more clearly
if you were if you were making a a tv
show about this
you said how do we script a totally
justified police intervention you would
say
in the moments before i'm going to i'm
going to commit this crime i'm going to
do
i'm going to use deadly force on you
innocent person
bang bang bang not just that we have
more footage from the cops of
of a girl who was attacked saying yes
the girl with the knife was coming after
me
she came out at you with a knife earlier
no she just
that's what the guy that's why the
police she came after me
with a knife yeah so she so he got her
yeah she came after me with a knife and
it's the woman who's wearing the really
bright pink outfit that you can all see
in the video
and you see the cop is walking up
doesn't sound like a white guy cop by
the way either and the woman says yes
she was coming after me she was coming
after me according to the columbus
dispatch
a neighbor said that the this cop saved
lives donovan brinson who's a neighbor
to mckia bryant's
foster home says quote and this is being
reported now by the columbus dispatch
while what happened is tragic brinson
said it all happened so fast that he
didn't see how the officer could have
had time
to have done anything else he referenced
the girl scene in both bought police
body camera footage and on his own
camera footage who was wearing pink
who was the second female engaged with
brian in the scuffle brinson
said he really thinks more people might
have died
had police not taken action okay
clear as can be the one thing i want to
say before we move on to the media which
is actually what i'm interested in
talking about here
is
the circumstances of this are
deeply deeply sad the cop did absolutely
the right thing he's a hero he should
win awards for what he did and he
saved lives very likely as this
neighbor says as the columbus dispatch
is reporting as the woman who was about
to be stabbed is saying right
he did that however it's a it is a very
sad thing
that this girl makia bryant
did not have good parents it's a very
sad thing
that this girl makia bryant was put into
the foster care system
i was thinking about this last night
thinking about this story a lot
obviously so i'm looking at my cute
little baby boy my newborn baby
and i'm thinking this kid at lea
you know at least now i think we're all
healthy we're all here has these two
loving parents
who are giving him every single
advantage
they possibly can i think about myself
when i was a little kid
how important it was that i had loving
parents
around me all the time devoted parents
who who
would give anything for me and this girl
makia bryant did not
she had bad parents and she was raised
in a bad culture
around bad people in a bad system
and that's not the fault of the
patriarchy or the white supremacy it's
the fault
of her bad parents and her bad family
around her that's whose fault it is and
that's really sad and they failed her
and they they deserve she does not
deserve all the blame
for her situation she chose to do what
she did with the knife and she faced the
consequences for that
her family bears quite a lot of blame
too though for putting her
in this this awful upbringing for not
educating her correctly for not taking
care of her for not loving her
they they deserve blame too and
i think you're going to see a lot of
people who you're going to see like the
second cousin twice removed of makia
bryant
now coming in and trying to milk this
situation for some money from the state
which is even even more
degrading and pathetic but really they
should all be
looking inward at themselves and what
what they have done here hey hold up a
second there
if by some chance we are still on
youtube even after reading this study
from the nih describing how dumb
and bad the masks are then you should
make sure
you smash that button subscribe like
make sure that you get more of these
videos
because i think youtube doesn't
necessarily
want to promote them all the time so
make sure that you do not miss
a video
you